The joe rogan experience.
Cause I feel like Spotify just dominates the market.
Yeah.
But see,
apple music's on everyone's phone now and you just find it and use it.
It's so easy to use,
but you don't,
you don't use Spotify.
See.
But I think it's the,
the youngest generation loves Spotify.
Like they love soundcloud.
Soundcloud,
I mean was so big.
They loved it.
Yeah.
They sound cloud.
A lot of people were using the host podcasts.
Yeah,
totally.
But a lot of people think that it won't be around.
Oh,
I think that's the opposite.
Not only do I think,
not only is it for stuff like that,
that's homemade podcast stuff like DIY,
it's also set to surpass Spotify paid paid subscribers.
Right,
right.
Cause Spotify starts off for free.
Right,
right.
Interesting.
Um,
but like that's my thing is like,
uh,
you know,
like that the future of soundcloud thing like that is because it's,
it's all,
everybody loves DIY shit.
Whether it's musicians or like all those musicians and artists now that are on
Spotify,
it's all people like making music in their fucking,
in their house.
Fucking youtube.
You know.
I mean,
how many youtube millionaires have been made from a lot.
So many weird shit.
Putting up videos,
talking.
I know some from that.
I know some from the beginning,
like I used to do a youtube sketch thing a long time ago and like caught fire a
little bit on a very small scale and the people that we kind of associated with
when it was starting to grow,
two or three of them now that I know have made so much money from them and they
were just from the jump,
they were kind of like in right as the cusp was like beginning.
You know what happens with that dude who got in trouble with the suicide?
Is it Jager?
Logan Paul.
Which one is he?
Logan.
Paul Logan.
Paul.
He's,
he's banned.
They don't,
they demonetize his entire channel and I thought he's still making videos.
Right?
If he's not making any money,
they took all his ad money away because he electrocuted a dead rat.
No.
Yes.
He did a video yesterday at two and a half.
A million views.
So,
but he doesn't get paid.
No,
there were saying that it's his entire channel was demonetized unless he got
lawyers involved.
So then he could be just using his channel and then getting sponsored videos,
maybe money and selling merchant,
which is one of the big things to me,
it's stunning.
Makes more unmerge probably then he doesn't from fucking youtube probably does
it.
To me it's stunning that there's not a competitor to Youtube.
Not a real competitor.
Yeah,
there's been tried.
They've tried.
It's crazy.
Vimeo is just not,
not happening.
Well it's a video hosting site,
but it's not,
it's not as user friendly.
Well,
it's also doesn't suggest things their algorithm that youtube is telling about
to having what's next on the right hand side.
It's like so attractive because there's always something there to click on Vimeo
does dot.
Isn't that they're not as sophisticated in that way.
They want to be the artistic,
uh,
you know,
co Coulter,
they want to cultivate like the sexy little artistic thing.
Youtube is like,
fuck it.
Here's everything we've,
you've ever wanted to see.
And ads for tampons.
We had,
um,
W W we're putting up every video on Vimeo as well as on Youtube.
But on youtube it will have over a million videos,
a million hits.
And then you go to Vimeo and the same video we'll have like,
what,
20,
30,000,
20,000.
Yeah,
that's,
I was gonna say,
cause there,
there's is so sick,
their viewer traffic is so much lower.
It's so much lower.
The only time I've watched Vimeo is when someone sends me a Vimeo link.
And you've got to think that video link is being sent to whatever million people
I have on Twitter.
Totally.
I have like 2 million people in 2 million Russian bots.
I'm not sure which one.
They're all bought suits.
I don't,
I don't know how that works.
And even about some of them,
they say it's,
if you haven't used it to post,
but there's a lot of people that use Twitter and they don't post.
So like,
how do you know if someone's a Bot,
like there's some suspicion of their,
um,
their detection methods to decide who's high.
Always can tell when you look at their fucking profile,
the stuff they write is so funny.
Oh,
there's definitely some of those.
You know what,
I get a lot of those on Instagram.
Get a lot of those.
Really?
Yeah.
Weird.
Like fake comments,
you know,
like a,
I learned how to make $109 a week.
It's all over the place.
Those things are everywhere.
Okay.